okay variations so well hopefully I'll
be talking about sarcastic optimization
VLP if yeah a lot of complete klutz
so yeah so good what was I gonna say
stochastic optimization VLPs and I'm not
going to be talking about convex
relaxation so the the the title
advertised outside is little erroneous a
little louder date but okay let me dive
right in the the general problem is how
do you model uncertainty in the inputs
usually the classic model of
optimization we work with is the inputs
are given and I saw the problem exactly
but maybe I don't quite know other
inputs maybe data is not available I
need to make some decisions before I
make the input before I make decisions
so I so and of course you know sometimes
I might not have the data exactly it
might take me more time to get the exact
data so I might have stochastic
predictions about the future and so this
is the model that we are going to work
with I'm going to make the model precise
in a minute this is not a new model it's
been around since the fifties or even
before perhaps then they had a paper in
55 where he talked about you know
computation with the uncertainty and so
you know there's the question of how do
you design algorithms that do well when
the input is uncertain is a sort of
basic question a lot of us have worked
on this before before so let me tell you
the model that I'm going to be working
with basically you should think of this
as the following you have given a bunch
of random variables what do I mean by
given random variables you know their
distributions okay the outcomes are not
known a priori but you have to make
decisions so one thing you could say is
look I'm going to look at all the random
variables and look at their outcomes and
then make the decision but there is
either an explicit or implicit cost to
figuring out the outcomes okay and we'll
make this precise for different problems
it would be different and so what what
can you do now so one particular
possibility is that the random variables
have the mass all on one possible value
and since you know the distribution this
is really just deterministic
optimization so this is the
generalization of that paradigm but you
know things get more interesting
so for this talk I'm going to assume
that the these random variables are
going to be independent they will see
some cases where they aren't and I'm
going to assume that the distribution is
given explicitly there are models where
you might assume that you're given black
box access to the distributions but
those are more complicated so here's an
example this is the classic knapsack
problem a bag of size B a bunch of items
so items with Rewards they have sizes
they have rewards you want to fit as
many items as you can into the bag
maximize it warn everybody know this
problem right so in the stochastic
question now these things are no longer
just single values so you have
distributions on size reward pairs and
let me show you an example so what's
going to happen is that the first item
is going to take on this size and give
you ten bucks with 60% probability and
this size in this value with 40% and so
on so forth so each item is now a
distribution over possible realizations
and one operation is allowed basically
what's the operation you choose an item
you don't know its outcome you see the
outcome you take it on the chin and move
on you choose the next thing and you do
the decision you know an outcome comes
you you you figure out what you want to
do next
you chose the third item and oops I went
over size I won't get value for this one
and the process stops here okay is the
model clear what do I want to do I want
to maximize my expected reward so now
the reward should have an expectation
sitting out there we could look at
different objective functions but this
is the one that we're going to focus on
wait it's not the order is important
absolutely
so now what's our solution concept so by
the way what's happening is the
algorithm is kind of actively causing
the the uncertainty to be resolved over
time what's the solution concept the
solution concept is now a decision tree
it's this massive thing and you know
what's going to happen is that you know
it's going to look like this
I put item 1 let's say and the sizes
came out to be you know either 0 or 5
based on these things I have to make
decisions so now my solution concept
itself might be exponentially sized
I can't even write down the optimal
solution in poly time by the way I'm
coming from the Seraph approximations
perspective I want to do everything in
poly time so that's that's how yardstick
right good and by the way I should I
should thank Yann and Michelle because
I've stolen shamelessly from their their
paper on the subject so the stochastic
knapsack was defined by Dean comments in
bondrock I think in 2005 or so oh by the
way so you know just these are the
rewards you are getting along the
various decision paths and you take the
expectation okay prom clear everybody
happy good so this is the expected
reward and so the the the solution
concept decision tree or dynamic program
you can do these things we are a dynamic
program it's exponentially sized and
it's not surprising you know this is a
special case of a Markov decision
process with the exponential size state
space you can just run a dynamic program
one idea you know easy to solve that way
but just just takes a lot of time in
space so what do we want to do we want
to do something there
and this is where the connection with
this workshop is going to come in we're
going to use the LP there's a crutch by
the way so you know coming back to
Sasha's question you know it's special
class of policy there's a non adaptive
policy I'm just going to write a list
I'm going to look at the first item on
the list I'm gonna put it in
and you know it fits it doesn't fit I
figure it out they go on to the next
date and I just keep going this way this
is a very degenerate decision tree and
one could ask the question well you know
how much do you lose by sticking to such
a non adaptive policy what's the power
of adaptivity or you could call it the
adaptivity gap so ideally we would like
algorithms which are a you know we can
approximate well but B for which the
adaptivity gap is more because then I
can just write down a list instead of
having to you know maintain some kind of
complicated decision tree so you know
the adaptivity gap can be more than one
this is a little example you can just
run this in your mind run this offline
and you can show that the best adaptive
solution has 2.5 value the best non
adaptive one has 2.05 so you know
there's some gap and the question that
we would also like to understand is how
big can this gap be for various problems
so good so we want a good approximation
ratio and for the one person in the
audience who doesn't know what an
approximation ratio is the ratio between
optimal algis our algorithm opt is the
optimal solution value and an ideal
solution as I said is give a poly time
simple simplicity's in the eye of the
beholder I understand but at least poly
time and non adaptive policies or
technical definitions that compares well
to the best adaptive as in massive
decision tree policy both at one fell
swoop is what we would like to do and
and this is where LPS come in and this
is how we're going to do this and I will
give you a general approach that we use
and we use LP is in a slightly different
way very slightly different way from
standard combinatorial optimization
how do you use that in combination
optimization you have a discrete problem
you think about it and you write it as
an integer linear program and you might
need smarts to do this and then you
relax it and you get an LP and
immediately oh by the way this is a
maximization problem so relaxing is only
increasing the value and now you solve
this LP and you come up with some
rounding approach it might be randomized
and then you interpret this integer
solution and you say well I've got at
least at alpha fraction of the LP value
and chaining these two together at least
in an alpha fractional form so now what
happens in stochastic problems do you
think is that the ILP the variables were
kind of encoding the decisions we were
making but the decisions were just you
know a set for a sequence but now I had
this decision tree so if I write the
naive LP I'm going to have a exponential
size LP it's no good so what I want to
do is I want kind of project down onto a
small LP and usually this requires some
effort very often we'll come up with an
LP and we'll have to actually do some
work to show that the LP is the
relaxation and often I you know I think
about it I don't think about it as a
relaxation I often think about it as a
surrogate this is somehow capturing some
aspects of this stochastic problem and
then I do a rounding and I might get an
integer solution but maybe this integer
solution has to you know it has to live
in this stochastic world it might not be
clear right now why an integer solution
is not the end of the game you have to
kind of interpret it back as the
stochastic policy
and this whole process you know we'll
have to do and let me give you an
example maybe this is too abstract okay
so let's look at the following problem
it's a very simple case of the knapsack
problem it's called the best box problem
but actually maybe it's not a special
case but it's very closely related to
the knapsack problem I give you n boxes
each one is the random variable okay
this thing should be X I the variables
are independent you don't know the
outcomes but you know the distributions
you are allowed to open any K of these
boxes look at the values inside and then
pick one of the open boxes and you want
to maximize the value maximize the
expected
is the problem clear you see the actual
instantiation of the random variable
thank you for everybody happy with this
prom questions answers let's go on again
it's a simple MVP you know you can you
can maintain the entire state and you
know use dynamic programming but we
don't want to do that so how do we you
know bound the value of art that's the
real question and here's how we're going
to do it we're gonna write an LP and
this LP looks and weird but let me just
you know so think of the variables X I
as being the probability that the
strategy whenever I do this thing I'm
imagining this decision tree in my mind
by the way so if you want to imagine the
same thing in decision tree so what's
the probability that overall the sample
paths that decision tree opens box I
that's a variable X I and Y IV is the
probability that box is opened and it
has value V
so oh sorry
and that I chose it we good yeah this is
the final one so so let me look at this
constraint I'm going to choose one
business it's gonna take on some value
so the y IV variable should sum up to at
most 1 now go to open at most k boxes if
I open a box I'm going to be able to
choose it with value V only if you know
if I open the box and the value V came
up so this is less than equal to I might
not choose it after all
if I chose I at value VI get V that's it
everything's non-negative are you happy
this is the first claim you have to do
is that you have to show that LP is that
more stop the at least stopped it's not
completely it's sort of immediate you
have to think for a minute at least and
once you think about it you realize the
following thing you know let's look at
that decision tree and let's look at one
sample path one decision path down the
tree these inequalities now are just
zero one things these are just
indicators this I have for indicated by
the way each of these equality's is
correct in the zero one interpretation
along a decision path and now take
expectations you know to make this
formal you might have to appeal to a
martingale argument but don't worry it's
okay
as Nikhil said the other day you know
martingale Ferrer friends so it's okay
everything's all right excellent
so probability that I opened I depends
only on decisions before I open I and I
assume that the random variables are
independent of each other so the outcome
of the ayats random variable is going to
be independent of the decisions I made
until I opened I then depend on the
values of the other guys but not on I
very crucial thank you
be good so far okay so now I need to
show you that the you know now I need to
give you an algorithm for this problem
and you know that there's only so much
that I can do out here and I promise not
to write in the margins so let me let me
let me tell you
so I solved this LP LP that lis stopped
now here's the algorithm all the boxes
in whatever order 1 through n whatever
for each I open box I with probability
this much whatever the LP tells you over
to and you'll see why / - if you know I
haven't already picked K boxes if I've
already picked K boxes I can't open a
box if I've already chosen a box earlier
I can't open another box but if not keep
going and now you look at the value and
somehow the X's have turned into V is
again so if the value turns out to be V
choose this box with probability this
much you know you should think of this
as the conditional probability and stop
so what am i doing I'm opening the first
box with some probability once I see the
value I'm going to choose it with some
probability and stop right away I'm not
even going to open the second box even
though I'm allowed
absolutely you know if I if I did the
smart thing and I actually open K boxes
I would do at least as much but in some
cases it might be you know a prompt
decision might be required and sometimes
it's helpful so the algorithmic leymah
the algorithm gets value LP over four
and here's the here's the proof and the
only idea is hardly an idea is Markov's
inequality since I'm opening every box
by a probability which has been shaded
down by 1/2 in expectation I am opening
up K over 2 boxes so the probability
that I end up opening K boxes is that
most 1/2 probability that a pick I with
value V is the probability that I reach
I which happens with probability 1/2
probably I open I which happens with
this much probability the probability
that I saw value V which happens with
probability P IV and then the
probability that I actually true like
which happens with this much probability
let's multiply all of all four of them I
assure you will get Y I / 4 y IV / 4
which is the objective function in the
LP divided by 4 so I lost a factor of 4
trivia
and somehow you know maybe you know a
quarter of the problems that we want to
solve the first LP that you write down
will be this kind of LP you'll get a
constant and you'll know at least hey
it's in the it's in this ballpark and
then you can try to improve okay by the
way you can improve this using a fancier
and fancier rounding algorithm to a
factor of half it does not go down so at
least this with this ask me again and
I'll have to think about that
probably one can do something
actually yeah okay anyways so quick
things this is like a query comic
solution I look at your value and I
immediately tell you whether I'm gonna
to view or not and this was kind of
useful you know people use these to
model kind of kidney exchange random
matching problems and there you kind of
want to make decisions quickly so this
might be a good abstraction for that
more careful algorithm and analysis
factor of two can we get a 1 plus
epsilon approximation that's a question
that I don't know the answer to
you know the idea is like this I I
realized I'm I I was too adventurous I
planned too much so I'm not going to be
able to talk about much of the stuff
that's in the slide I'll leave through
them so you can look on the YouTube
channel anything I guess so stochastic
knapsack if you want to solve stochastic
knapsack remember this problem what am I
going to do well you know just notation
ri is the reward si is the size I'm
going to assume that the reward is
deterministic just for the next couple
of slides and I'm going to assume that
the sizes are not bigger than the size
of the knapsack you can handle this this
the general case but let me just make
life easy and now the LP and there's one
idea on this slide that I want to
mention very quick so the LP is going to
be you know X is again what's the
probability that item I is inserted into
the knapsack reward I times X I
expected size of I times X I this must
sum up to and for some weird reason I'm
putting in to be out here and you will
see why in forum in a moment why so you
know decision tree and what's happening
Fitz Fitz Fitz oops didn't fit how big
can the size be it must be and all the
stuff I put earlier whether it must be
so that's it most to be and in fact you
need this factor of two to make the
argument kosher and I can show you you
know cute little examples very simple
and the argument is exactly the same
this just shows you you don't need to
read this it's exactly the same argument
and what do you do you do things like oh
you know to be looks annoying to me I'll
just scale it down to be that's okay
factor of two loss it's an LP now what
do I do with this hey it's a knapsack LP
I know exactly what the solution looks
like we've all solved knapsack L please
put the densest element first and you
keep filling in until some point you you
you go over and then you take some
fraction of it and then what can you do
well you know what's the optimal
solution the optimal reward is the
reward of the first K guys plus some
fraction of this let's just round this
up at most the reward of the first k
plus one guys
so the optimal solution is with
probability half pick this guy just this
nice guy and with probably half pick a
random ordering of this guy and go over
them and I'm not going to give you the
argument the argument uses the mark of
the inequality a couple of times
please
I'll say that again
so so X I we were thinking when we were
arguing so maybe let me go back so the
first argument I had to make was that
this LP is relatable to the optimal
solution so when I'm thinking of saying
that there is a feasible solution I'm
thinking of X is being the probability
the probability over what the optimal
decision so maybe I should have put in X
I less than equal to 1
thank you yeah yeah yeah that's a very
good point thank you rhythm you should
have asked this thing if you see more
bugs on this thing you know feel free to
you know raise your hand
it's good okay it is the probability and
then if I want to solve this then I
clearly I'm going to get one otherwise
I'll oh yeah I'll run into trouble out
here anyways and you can get a factor of
you know some constant factor if you
just run this algorithm and there is
stuff on the next slide but I'm going to
spare you you know I'm standing between
you and lunch I realize that you know it
looks it looks painful but it's it's all
elementary I assure you okay okay you
can write better LP relaxations we did
not use almost sort of any properties of
Independence no okay we used it once in
the LP we could use more and these for
those of you who know the stuff might
remind you of these border type
inequalities which people use in revenue
maximization settings and if you use
those you can write a better LP again
from the same paper and you can reduce
the integrality gap down to four oh and
you can solve this LP this is just a
poly metric
so you can get a for approximation also
an adaptability gap I am giving you an
on adaptive solution you can get a three
approximation adaptive you can improve
its own Jeep sitting out there one of
his very nice papers gave a 2 plus
epsilon approximate adaptive you can do
stuff questions I want to ask are better
relaxations hardness actually I don't
know how to show hardness for this
problem beyond the basic you know we can
P hardness I get from the knapsack yes
so suppose I want to I want to compare
to the optimal policy and I'm happy with
the 1 plus epsilon approximation
Sanjeev almost gets this but he has to
violate the capacity by a tiny bit I
don't want to do that this is the
bonafide knapsack problem so I'll wait
for me or show me hardness in okay and
you can use this idea to prove a whole
bunch of stuff by the way so Rakesh Bora
has this little monograph on using LP
techniques for auction design problems
and he's got a very nice proof of
meyerson's theorem the the meyerson's
theorem revenue maximized options in the
Bayesian setting we are just very simple
ideas like this what is the probability
that item I is given to buyer B these
are what I call marginal based lp's
there are cases where such simple lp's
are not enough and I'll maybe just flash
this and another I should stop so one
thing that we did was suppose I times
rewards and sizes were correlating so
here's a job that you know it's it's a
job that almost immediately it it's
going to crash I'm going to give me the
arrow reward but with some tiny
probability it will run through the end
and give me some high reward and here is
the job which is always guaranteed to
you know have size to reward one would
probably want and if you just look at
the expected rewards and the expected
sizes separately they look exactly the
same so we are not capturing
correlations and what we might want to
do is we might want to capture
correlations so simple LP might not go
too far you can write more fancier LPS
and I'll just show you some LP you know
that works I don't expect you to
understand I mean basically it's somehow
saying what's the probability that a job
that started at time s finished by time
T or not I know things like this you can
write fancier page you can do rounding
there's a dot let me
clearly I was overestimating how much I
could do okay
so let me wrap up the you know
high-level catch me later on if you
would like to know more you know LP bass
relaxing round techniques very powerful
in stochastic optimization and out here
we we were using LP slightly differently
we wanted to model this exponential
sized object so we use LP that
surrogates and there will they might be
you know essentially a loss out there
we're trying to understand how well you
can do that there lots of techniques
that are used I've just mentioned some
some some techniques out here sometimes
we can't argue about the decision tree
via LPS or we don't know how to do it so
for instance the orienteering problem
for those of you who know who that what
that is we don't know how to write we
didn't know how to write an LP until by
recently Swami is going to talk about
that later on maybe we can always use
the LP techniques I don't know constants
are usually poorer than the
deterministic problems can we close the
gap hardness and one question that I'm
really interested in nowadays is what we
assume that distributions were known
maybe the distributions are not known
maybe I need to learn them and this goes
back to when Rex talked last week for
those of you who are there you know I
want to learn the distributions well
enough to solve my problem I don't want
to learn it well enough to you know in
TV distance I don't care how well should
I
that's it from me thank you
[Applause]
is there some sense of why certain
problems it with peaceful
I tried but I don't have a good sense
for and in some cases you know there are
problems so one thing I did not mention
that there are problems for which the
integrality gap is not constant but it's
like a log-log integrality gap and the
log log is essential there is a very
nice paper of nickel pencil and others
which shows a log-log integrality here
so there are problems you know unusual
things might happen that I don't quite
understand well enough to be able to say
anything meaningful absolutely so for
many problems I just need to know very
basic statistics about these things but
for some problems so then those problems
would be easy as long as I can prove a
kind of a robustness guarantee that it
does not depend too much on the error
out there but for other problems you
know it would be more interesting
I'll just be one the margins you know
does this so
I was trying to think of an example
yesterday when I was making the talk you
know is there a Sarah Adams version of
this thing it's a nun that come to mind
right now but you know let me think
about that again so so so this is pspace
heart so in fact there's you know a
couple of variants of the stochastic
knapsack problem and Jana and Michele in
the paper have a Dean commenting on drag
have the examples where the problem is
pspace hard but they're these are
certain variants of the problem there
are other variants for which we don't
know and you have to define just so to
get the G space sickness
okay let's take a moment
[Applause]